to today because it is National pie day
and we are celebrating with Emeril
Lagasse's Infamous banana cream pie that
you can get at Delmonico Steakhouse and
joining us today we have Chef Yvonne
Rojas thank you so much for being here
you're welcome so I love banana cream
pie and I know that Emeril Lagasse's
recipe is one of the best so I don't
know if you can spill any secrets but
tell me about the pie what makes it so
delicious well you got that right yeah
he's up Chef Emerald's banana cream pie
is a signature dishes on our restaurants
here Emerald's New Orleans Fish House at
the MGM and Delmonico Steakhouse so I
mean the recipe is very um you know
basic ingredients so you got you got
eggs you got sugar you got bananas you
got butter in there and then that's
basically that recipe we start with um
graham cracker crust and then Each pie
it will take like 12 to 14 bananas and
then we put that in into the pies we got
layers of our pastry cream three layers
of banana pastry cream and then we
finish with um fresh whipped cream oh
yes I thought it already looked
delicious but I say we top it off so I
can take a bite
with the whipped cream okay let's do
this here and you said 12 to 14 bananas
and 14 bananas yes you can see all these
beautiful layers yeah we have a close-up
on the screen here wow look at that oh
my gosh I never have enough whipped
cream that's my theory fresh fruit cream
on top okay A little bit of um caramel
sauce on top okay
a little sweetness there
and then we're gonna finish with the
chocolate shavings on top looks amazing
I used to watch Emerald's cooking show
Growing Up he would always say bam
look how beautiful this is is it time
for me to take a bite please okay I'm
gonna go in and take a bite and I'm a
strong believer dessert before dinner
but if you come in for dinner what do
you recommend trying on the menu you
guys are known for your steaks right
well definitely
um uh our dry age program we have in the
restaurant because definitely the bone
and rebuy I mean I'm a big fan big fan
of the riba so definitely the bone
ribeye it's it's one of the most popular
desserts I mean um entries on the on the
restaurant I know where we're distracted
by desserts right now but you got to
come in for the states okay I'm going in
this is a really big bite so I'm not
sure how cute this will look on TV but
we're going for it I have to try it Chef
thank you so much for you're welcome oh
my goodness
can I keep this whole thing for myself
absolutely 100 thank you so much
and the show here and just eat pie all
day happy National pie day go check out
the Monaco